there was another big racial incident
okay this time it was in atlanta
someone painted several racist and
defensive slurs on a building at emory
university in atlanta i've spoken at
emory before it's a pretty left-wing
place
and at the time the local news outlet
wsb tv
reported that the emory autism center
has become the target of several crimes
including burglary and vandalism
including graffiti of racial slurs and
swastikas
a police report of the incident
showed that vending machines had been
vandalized glass had been shattered
quote the area where racial slurs were
reportedly written along the walls or
near the workspace occupied by two
african-american women a swastika was
found in a hallway near a jewish man's
office
at the time the school says the acts of
racism and anti-semitism are painful for
all of us at the eac and in the emory
community they will not be tolerated and
every effort will be made to bring the
perpetrators
to justice when i saw this story
without knowing anything else
but i hadn't seen the picture of the guy
who perpetrated it i looked at that i
said that's a hoax
that's a hoax that's not a white
supremacist it's not a neo-nazi
it's a race hoax
being perpetrated by big libs
by left-wingers
very likely by a black guy
you know i hate to say i told you so but
i was right for hims.com is all about
men's wellness need help with ed hair
loss have a cold
interested in mental health or
coronavirus home tests kim's is here for
you through hymns you can get the
prescription medication that treats ed
real science real solutions to ed you
get the same active ingredient as that
expensive little pill but without the
expensive price tag this could cost
hundreds of dollars if you had to go
through a doctor or pharmacy
not so
with hymns hymns makes it simple and
affordable why live with ed when the
solution can be so
simple take control of your wellness i
know that men don't always like to talk
about these sorts of things well hymns
makes it so simple easy
try hymns today by going for a free
online visit go to for hims.com michael
for your free visit that is for hims.com
michael f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot com slash
michael prescription products are
subject to medical provider approval and
require an online consultation with a
medical provider who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate see website
for full details and safety information
that is for hims.com
michael turns out the perpetrator is
black he's a black guy i i detail a lot
of these incidents in my book speechless
so many of the high
the majority of the of the highest
profile racial incidents
in recent decades
turned out to be hoaxes
the allegedly oppressed people
were the ones who set the whole thing up
in the first place
why is that well you can see you you see
it in the
the statement given by this by the
school
the acts of racism and anti-semitism are
painful for all of us stop it right
there
no they're not they're pleasurable
these are pleasurable incidents
for people who can claim victimhood and
therefore social currency and for the
ruling class that seeks to divide us
these racial incidents these hoaxes are
extremely pleasurable because it
advances their political goals
they're not pain they're painful for the
people who are accused of bigotry and
racism and whose rights and way of life
are being taken away
as a result of that but it's pleasurable
for for the people who who benefit from
it
this is why
they so often turn out to be hoaxes
because there is a real
advantage to being able to claim
victimhood i'm so glad that you like
that clip that makes me feel
really good you can leave me a comment
here on youtube you can subscribe on
youtube but the thing that i would love
most
is if you would go to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play type in
the
michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]